the internet-of-things promises big
opportunities for developers to
contribute to the huge growth of devices
hitting the market but have you ever
stopped to think about what it really
takes to build a connected product at
scale my name is Dave Smith and today
I'm going to show you how Android things
can help you build smart connected
devices for IOT Android thing's is an
extension of Android designed to enable
developers to build high quality secure
devices and maintain them at scale the
platform is made up of three core
elements a variant of Android that has
been optimized for use in IOT secure and
managed updates direct from Google and
powerful hardware that's accessible and
easy to integrate let's begin with the
software running on the device with
Android things you can build apps using
the rich framework provided by the
Android SDK and Google Play services
including the same UI toolkit Multimedia
support and connectivity API is used by
mobile developers today your apps can
easily integrate with popular Google
services like firebase tensorflow
and the Google cloud platform using the
many existing Android client libraries
and of course you can develop using all
the same languages and tools supported
for Android development today to improve
the Android experience for embedded use
we've tuned the platform for faster boot
times and lower memory footprint
including a smaller variant of Google
Play services optimized specifically for
IOT we've also added new API s through
the Android things support library to
better integrate your apps with custom
hardware this includes expanded support
for peripheral interfaces and device
management Android things does not
include user facing apps like a launcher
or browser instead it is designed to
boot directly into the apps you've built
for your device Google takes care of
providing updates and security patches
to the core operating system so you can
focus on your app this means you get to
take advantage of our ongoing work on
Android to keep your devices secure and
protect your users system images are
signed by Google and verified for
integrity on device this prevents a
corrupt or tampered update from being
applied Android seamless a B updates
apply the image in the
ground without interrupting the
application failure to boot following an
update will roll back to the previous
version ensuring the system always boots
into a known good state updates are
delivered over-the-air from the Android
things console using the same secure
infrastructure we use to update mobile
devices today we can even push updates
automatically when security patches are
available for the platform apps on the
device are managed exclusively through
the console and bundled with each update
this means that Android things does not
include the Google Play Store because
user installed apps are not supported
building production devices with Android
things is a turnkey process thanks to
the system on module or somme
architecture each module is a fully
integrated component that you can drop
directly into your final design the same
way you would integrate a framework or
library into your app modules are
manufactured in high volume by the chip
vendors enabling you to purchase them at
low cost whether you need to buy 110 or
10,000 Android things hardware is pre
certified by Google with a board Support
Package provided by our vendor partners
these partnerships enable us to deliver
long-term support for each stable
release across our entire Hardware
lineup the hardware is also pre
certified with regulatory agencies like
the FCC simplifying the certification
testing required to take your product to
market and further saving you time and
money
Android thing's is so much more than
just a cool new form factor for building
your apps secure system updates and
accessible Hardware make it a reliable
platform for connected devices at scale
to learn more about how to get started
visit the documentation and check out
our samples and drivers on github also
join our community so you can ask
questions share your projects and stay
up to date with the latest platform
announcements thanks so much for
watching today and I look forward to
seeing what you build with Android
things i'm dave smith and i'll see you
next time
[Music]